rage I'm with all that's going on in the
country in the world right now I found
this next news story really odd check
this out the Trump administration has
hit Canada our closest neighbor and
probably one of our closest allies with
a 24 percent tax on lumber imported from
Canada this is yeah story yes I was just
you see the story it's kind of nuts it's
nuts yeah it's very bizarre that this is
what our administration is focusing on
lumber tariffs on Canada
it seems nuts but then I had this vague
memory
we interviewed voters back on Election
Day I forgot about it
and I went back and looked at it and
things are starting to make sense check
it out in the upcoming election who
you're gonna be voting for Donald Trump
why is that I like it stance on Canadian
lumber imports what's the most important
issue for you in the upcoming election
taxes on Canadian lumber imports as a
woman I definitely have to say tariffs
on Canadian lumber Canadian lumber in
force we got to text them well fati fuss
and throw them at community
I just want my baby to grow up in a
world where there's a tariff on Canadian
lumber imports so obviously you're
voting for Donald Trump next week right
yes I am because we need to make America
great again by slapping the 24% imports
out from Canadian lumber
I remember those shirts though strips
are very popular
you